okay so this is a part two to my
previous video
anatomy of a headshot it's not required
that you watch it but it would
definitely make this video a little bit
easier to
understand firstly i just want to
preface this by saying that the majority
of people who are shot in the head
die there's no question about it but
there are some rare cases where people
have lived
the cases that i'll mention later in
this video are people who had incredibly
rare circumstances that ultimately save
their lives
exact replication of these circumstances
doesn't mean one would have the same
outcome as these survivors
they are the exception not the rule
surviving a gunshot to the head
is not like recovering from a broken arm
or leg it results in life-altering
effects of mental emotional and physical
hardships
even with full recovery the victim is
usually never the same
so just to clear some things up when i
say shot in the head
i don't mean hear or hear or hear or
hear
by shot in the head i specifically mean
a bullet penetrates your skull and goes
directly into your brain with that
cleared up let's look at various factors
that have to take place in order to give
you a chance to survive
the first thing you'll want is to not
get shot with a rifle or
shotgun as explained in my previous
video a rifle is a high-powered firearm
and the amount of kinetic energy the
bullet has as it strikes your skull
is far too much to give you a fighting
chance to survive and as for shotguns if
it's point blank or even a few feet away
you're not going to live i'm sure
there'll be some comments along the
lines of
well if you get shot with a 20 gauge
shotgun with bird shot from 20 feet away
you won't die idiot okay let's be real
here we're talking lethal distance with
lethal rounds either buckshot or a slug
within relatively close range like 5 or
6
feet not 100 yards away yes some people
do live after a self-inflicted shotgun
wound to the head but that's because
they didn't hit their brain
usually they end up taking off their
face or their jaw the gun is typically
aimed this way or this way where the
shot does not end up hitting the brain
or brain stem
i mean we're talking about a scenario
where you already have less than 10
chance of living on a good day if you
aim a shotgun at your head at close
distance with buckshot or slug and the
path is directly from barrel to brain
you're not going to live sorry for the
rant moving on
instead the best weapon to be shot with
to increase your chances to survive
is a low powered firearm like a pistol
or a 22 caliber rifle
the next factor is distance the farther
the distance the more time the bullet
has to lose energy
obviously if you're 150 yards away from
a low powered firearm
you have more chances of surviving the
opposite of a long distance shot is a
contact shot where the gun is placed
against your head and then fired
by the way here's an interesting fact
regarding shot distance
a forensic study gathered the results of
bullet exit wounds of multiple homicides
and suicides
when a bullet fully passes through a
skull it usually means it was fired at
close range or from a high-powered
firearm
if it does not pass through that means
it was fired from a long distance or a
low-powered firearm
it was discovered that 51 percent of
suicide resulted in the bullet passing
through the skull
whereas in homicides the bullet only
passed through 19
of the time this is because in most
suicides the method is via
a contact shot where the victim places
the gun against the head and then fires
so the bullet has peak energy when it
hits the skull
conversely in homicides the shot is
usually fired from a further distance
so the round does lose some energy next
to increase your chances of survival
it's important to only have one
hemisphere of your brain damaged either
left or right means less complications
and disruptions to connectivity in the
body
also the majority of the circulation for
the brain is located in the center
between the two hemispheres if a bullet
passes through here it could sever the
middle cerebral artery causing an
extraordinary amount of blood
loss finally the most important factor
in surviving a head shot is medical
response time
you could have the best case scenario
but if you don't have quick medical
attention
well you're going to die it's important
to know that sometimes people don't even
die right away after getting shot in the
head
don't get me wrong they're completely
incapacitated but they're able to
breathe on their own without assistance
from a machine
in one forensic investigation a man shot
himself in the head with a 357 magnum a
notoriously powerful handgun the victim
was unconscious and immobile but was
still alive and breathing for
approximately 1 hour and 34 minutes
before
finally dying this isn't to say that the
victim would have lived if they got
treatment it's just to show that
sometimes you don't actually die
immediately after getting shot in the
head and why medical response time is so
crucial
so the question is how is someone
treated when they're shot in the head
well it turns out that the procedure is
actually pretty straightforward when the
brain is injured it begins to swell if
it swells too much it will press
on the inside of the skull causing more
damage to itself to prevent this from
happening
part of the skull is removed in a
procedure known as a craniectomy this
allows the brain to expand and swell
without hurting itself
from here surgeons simply remove bullet
and skull fragments in any dead tissue
and allow the brain to take care of the
rest you see surgeons cannot treat torn
brain tissue like
regular tissue it can't have stitches
drawn through it or get bandaged up
brain tissue is full of billions of
neurons bandaging and pricking the
tissue with stitches would cause more
damage to these very sensitive nerve
cells
instead the patient is stabilized and
the brain is allowed to repair itself
amazingly the brain manages to repair
damaged tissue and rewire the neurons
over time fairly well it doesn't rewire
everything back to 100 percent but it
does a fairly good job in creating new
neural pathways
now that we know what it takes to
survive a headshot here is some real
life cases where a victim was shot in
the head
and under the right circumstances
survived and maintained a fairly normal
life
one night tammy sexton's husband came
home drunk like he had done many times
before
except this time it would end much
differently a fight ensued between the
two
her husband grabbed a 38 caliber pistol
shot her in the head and then himself
the bullet entered above her left eye
penetrated two inches deep into her
brain
ricocheted around the left side of her
skull and then exited behind her left
ear
amazingly when police arrived they
discovered sexton was not only alive but
she was making tea all the while with a
gunshot wound in her head
a combination of shock adrenaline and
most importantly the bullet missing
vital portions of her brain
allowed her to not only be alive but
conscious she was airlifted to usa
medical center and given a cranictomy
today she lives a normal life
[Music]
next is arguably the most famous gunshot
survivor in recent history
due to her fight for women's rights in
the middle east malala was a 15 year old
pakistani activist who was quite vocal
on social media about women's rights in
pakistan
despite receiving multiple death threats
on october 9th
2012 while walking to school with her
classmates a taliban gunman saw her
and ordered her to kneel down the gunman
drew a 45 caliber revolver
aimed it downward at her head and then
fired a single round
the bullet passed through her left eye
socket traveled through the middle part
of her left ear
and into her left shoulder due to the
trajectory of the bullet
only a small portion of the left frontal
lobe of her brain received damage
and it was limited to only one
hemisphere she was given a craniactomy
and later on recovered
she would go on to receive the nobel
peace prize for her actions on women's
rights
in august of 2006 rachel brzezinski was
a typical 17 year old high school
student
she and her friends had heard of an
abandoned haunted barn out on the
countryside
they drove to the barn at night and
walked onto the property
the owner of the property heard
trespassers and shot at them in the dark
with a 22 caliber rifle
one of the rounds struck berezinski on
the back right side of her head
passed from the right hemisphere into
the left hemisphere towards the front of
her head
and stopped just above her left eye the
22 caliber bullet was a hollow point so
when it struck her head it mushroomed
out and doubled in size
a total of four lobes in her brain were
damaged and even worse to blow across
both hemispheres
fortunately brzezinski was quickly
rushed to the hospital and underwent an
emergency craniectomy
though bullet and bone fragments were
removed from the brain the bullet itself
could not be recovered
additionally she had a portion of her
temporal lobe removed due to it being in
a necrotic state
though she has fully recovered she does
have memory issues
and continues physical therapy to this
day but overall has had a fairly normal
life
she was even featured on the cover of
people magazine in 2011.
the farmer who shot at a group of
teenagers in the dark nearly killing one
was sentenced to 19 years in prison
gabby giffords was an arizona
congresswoman representing arizona's 8th
congressional district
on january 8 2011 giffords was attending
a meet and greet with residents in her
district
in the crowd was a 23 year old paranoid
schizophrenic named jared loughner who
was in possession of a nine millimeter
handgun
loughner walked up to a table giffords
was sitting at and shot her directly in
the forehead from three feet away
the bullet entered above her left eye
passed through her brain
and exited out the back of her head two
factors contributing to gifford's
survival was the bullet only passed
through one hemisphere
thereby limiting damage to the rest of
her brain additionally
her campaign intern daniel hernandez jr
performed cpr on her
prolonging her life until medics could
transport her to the hospital
gifford's quick access to medical care
being a politician undoubtedly saved her
life
the bullet having damaged her frontal
lobe made it difficult for her to speak
and control voluntary movements
but following intense physical and
speech therapy she was able to make a
full recovery
in 2012 to show her notable improvement
she led the pledge of allegiance at the
democrat national convention
here's the pledge to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it
one nation under god
indivisible liberty and justice for
all
[Applause]
[Music]
at this rate it would seem that getting
shot in the head with a low-powered
firearm and then having immediate
medical attention right after
is the perfect formula to survive well
not exactly
there was one infamous case where
everything fit the criteria perfectly
and yet the victim did not live
specifically the assassination
of robert f kennedy robert kennedy was a
senator from massachusetts who was
running for president in 1968.
on june 5th kennedy gave a speech at the
ambassador hotel in los angeles
after winning the california primary
afterwards he exited through the hotel's
kitchen and greeted 17 year old busboy
juan romero
at that moment a jordanian national
sirhan sirhan walked up behind kennedy
and fired eight shots from a 22 caliber
handgun
four of the eight shots had hit kennedy
one behind his right ear
one at the top of his right shoulder and
two just to the left of his right armpit
he was rushed to good samaritan hospital
16 miles away
neurosurgeons performed a craniectomy
but were unable to remove the lodge
bullet and bone fragments from kennedy's
brain
over the course of 26 hours of intense
neural surgery robert f kennedy
eventually passed away
on june 6 1968. considering the
circumstances of the previous survivors
kennedy should have lived
he was shot with a low powered handgun
using a small caliber bullet only one
hemisphere of his brain was damaged
and he received immediate medical care
at first glance we could say
it's a luck of the draw that kennedy
died and they lived however
looking deeper we see that it's not the
case kennedy was shot with a low powered
handgun
and using a small caliber bullet yes he
only had one hemisphere affected
and yes he received top medical care but
one thing was very different in
kennedy's case than was in the rest
the location of the bullet the bullet
that entered behind kennedy's ear
damaged the right cerebellum and right
occipital cortex
this caused reduction in cerebral
functions and edema or a buildup of
fluid in the local area
the brain stem being adjacent to this
region was damaged due to this swelling
the brain stem is crucial in controlling
automatic functions like regulating
heart rate
breathing and sleeping a swelling brain
putting pressure on the brain stem would
damage it thereby causing the person to
stop breathing
in kennedy's case as fluid built up the
brain stem became more and more damaged
from the pressure thereby
interfering with signaling to the lungs
to breathe involuntarily
surgeons noted that as kennedy's
intracranial pressure increased his
breathing slowed down
to the point that he finally succumbed
at 1 44 am
on june 6th 26 hours after he was shot
it's important to remember that despite
these rare occurrences
surviving a gunshot to the head is the
exception not the rule
you